so far in 2022 streaming video accounted
for roughly half of the internet's
bandwidth with no signs of slowing down
this growth has not only strained
existing infrastructure but has also
challenged companies to expand the
presence of their content globally in
response companies have begun to look to
the public cloud to not only grow their
distribution infrastructure
but also expand it globally to serve
their viewers closer to where they are
solving for this has traditionally been
tricky for developers due to hurdles
such as complex configuration and
deployment this is why we introduced
media cdn a modern platform for
companies to efficiently scale and
deliver media content to anyone anywhere
on the globe all while providing a
seamless developer experience
let's take a closer look at media cdn by
walking through scenarios that an
imagined streaming service screening in
the cloud might face while trying to
build out their streaming service to
serve a global user base
screening in the cloud has a couple of
alpha customers in mind wendy and hanan
wendy is in sao paulo watching it on her
mobile phone and hanan is at home in
sydney on her fiber connection screening
in the cloud wants to serve their movies
to both of them in the highest possible
quality without excessive buffering or
choppiness
screening in the cloud cares about a few
key things that media cdn brings to the
table
the first is its global network that
allows them to serve their content as
close to wendy and hanan as possible
this is where media cdn shines because
its underlying infrastructure is
actually built on google's planet scale
network it's the same infrastructure
that supports youtube to serve videos to
users around the world
screening in the cloud gets to use this
network that spans more than 210
territories and 1300 cities screening in
the cloud can use this global network to
cache content from all of their origins
whether they're served via a google
cloud resource like a google cloud
storage bucket or reside in an origin
external to google cloud like within
hosts in their data centers that
predates their growth into the cloud as
screening in the cloud prepares to serve
their global user base with a production
ready service they'll be using another
set of features that sets media cdn
apart
those that ensure the delivery of their
content is secure this security spans
both secure content delivery and
policy-based restrictions that give
screening in the cloud granular control
on what is served where for securing
content delivery media cdn comes with
integrated ssl certificate management
there are no additional charges
associated with serving ssl traffic or
obtaining google managed certificates
after all protecting end user traffic
should not be at a premium
media cdn also adheres to the latest tls
support for better performance and
stronger encryption for their content
incorporating geo region and ip based
policies on their content
as far as controlling what content gets
delivered where screening in the cloud
can use cloud armor google's network
security service to apply allow and deny
list based rules
screening in the cloud for example may
have specific content that should not be
served to australia users as a whole
including hanan
to achieve this they can use gcloud to
create a security policy for media cdn
services and then attach a rule to that
policy that excludes users in australia
from accessing the specific content
they can then select the media cdn
service to which this policy applies and
attach it
with a few commands screening in the
cloud gets granular control over who can
access their content
security features are first class
citizens in the media cdn user
experience allowing for screening in the
cloud to be production ready
with origins set and security now
accounted for screening in the cloud can
begin to see the performance gains that
media cdn brings to the table with its
advanced caching
you see the global network that powers
media cdn is more than just google's
data centers rather it's google's data
centers points of presence and
integrations with isps that provide
multi-tiered caching functionality that
minimizes cache fill at each layer
ultimately this gives screening in the
cloud two key wins performance gains for
serving content close to the user and
origin shielding to reduce the load on
their own server's hosting content
finally screening in the cloud is eager
to deploy media cdn because it brought
an intuitive and well integrated
developer experience to their team this
experience spans the entire life cycle
of serving content from integrating with
the rest of their video delivery
pipeline to deploying the edge caches
for their content to monitoring and
logging these services in production in
the end screening in the cloud was able
to integrate media cdn with the rest of
their video delivery architecture
screening in the cloud first used the
transcoder api to translate the original
video file into multiple bit rates and
resolutions to provide appropriate
options for various device types and
network bandwidth of end users
the manifest file points to the various
video segments so that the end user's
video player can choose based on
availability bandwidth so that both
wendy and hanan can view the content
best suited for their internet
connectivity
given that with their global base comes
the potential for adding revenue streams
from advertising screening in the cloud
can add the video stitcher api to this
pipeline dynamically inserting ads into
their content before landing in its
origin fronted by media cdn screening in
the cloud also wants to make sure that
their service is not only performant but
reliable for all the users that come
after wendy and hanan
media cdn comes with integrated logging
and monitoring in cloud operations with
dashboards providing critical
information for their engineers
maintaining production
they can view information like cache
hits which display the quick performance
improvements that media cdn brings to
the table once enabled
they can also look at information like
blocked requests
which provide information that ensures
their security policies are working in
prod
and finally they can look at information
like response codes which can help them
quickly remediate issues that may affect
wendy and hanan's experience with the
content
to sum it up media cdn enabled screening
in the cloud too
utilize the same infrastructure that
powers youtube to serve rich content to
a global audience
achieve industry-leading offload rates
with deep caching infrastructure
reducing stress on origins
secure delivery of their content without
sacrificing performance
all while ensuring developers were able
to integrate this with the rest of their
video pipeline and their operations to
keep their services reliable
learn more by heading to
cloud.google.com
media cdn